good morning bradley
oh it looks like you slept on your
clothes again not to worry we need to
work on
that while it's already atm badging time
you need to be at your workplace in five
minutes
identity confirmed
uploading personal settings
tuesday
october 28 2031.
better get a move on
today will be mostly sunny with cloudy
periods and now a message from our
sponsors why there are so many ads in
the morning
bradley you have exactly four minutes if
you want to get to work on time
[Music]
by the way don't worry my eyesight it's
perfectly fine it's just that well over
the past couple of years i've gotten
fairly used to looking the world through
these glasses now these currently top of
the range on the oculus line they've got
plastic lenses less than a millimeter
thick main stereo camera visible here
and a couple of service ones they're
needed so the glasses recognize me in
person most importantly no buttons
oculus clearly responds to gestures and
understands my voice check this out
meta what's the date today today is the
best date to get your premium
subscription bradley welcome to the
brave new metaverse
uploading the host avatar
starting simulation exactly 10 years ago
today facebook's creator mark zuckerberg
changed the parent company's name to
meta
now at that time facebook was under an
avalanche of criticism the network is
being accused of spreading unverified
information about covert 19 an event
that as we now know was the main suspect
the troublesome 2020s dismissed
employees of the company were writing
complaints about mark himself even his
maids didn't shy away from truly
heart-wrenching reviews therefore most
journalists tended to agree that this
new name was intended to distract
investors attention from all of these
scandals
but only mark himself knew that his team
had money technology and a clear vision
of the future
all of that was needed to really start
that information revolution
by the way i'm sorry i have to leave you
for a short while i certainly didn't
come to china for the chicks
meta turn on protective mode protective
mode is on
now mark confirmed the seriousness of
this deed with his budget for the new
division
10 billion dollars just think about that
for a moment 10 billion that's the same
amount that was spent by elon musk
creating the global satellite system
known as starlink it's pretty easy to
see where elon's money went i mean
astronomers say that there are so many
styling satellites in space that they
seriously interfere with stargazing as
fewer stars are actually visible from
the earth as a result but what did
mark's team really spend the money on
the games of course the history books
say that the minesweeper and the
solitaire games appeared on windows with
a very interesting hidden function they
were added to the system to teach users
how to work with a mouse now the same
technique was used by the creators of
meta first of all they created a
platform with a lot of simple but yet
addictive games the main feature of the
platform was enabling the user's avatar
to freely move between games and at the
same time letting it carry objects
earning points loot and lots of other
things
they imagined that a player could be
picking up and reloading a gun in a
shooter and the next minute
well
the player would appear in a boxing ring
right and games aren't really separate
programs anymore in this space instead
they function as rooms along a long
hallway that one can access as they
please and a little later users of the
platform had the opportunity to create
simple games themselves metta had
published a map editor and a detailed
guide on creating relevant scripts
[Music]
but this didn't come without its full
backs experienced gamers maliciously
compared the platform to historical
games such as roblox and fortnite but
they failed to notice one thing more and
more new elements from other facebook
projects were appearing in the meta
universe
instagram and facebook news feeds could
be viewed from the virtual desktop the
avatar could take a picture in the
instagram photo booth and could directly
send a message to a friend on whatsapp
and gradually third party services began
to join the project too first it was
pinterest and it was spotify and then
adobe creative studio came around hello
now third party services effectively
turned mater's corridor rooms into
advanced and functional office spaces
you can assemble a virtual wall of
monitors and display anything on them
any applications channels or documents
working with such a representation
became much clearer and more convenient
than
fiddling around with the computer
settings right whenever you go to
virtual office the structure of
documents and available applications
remain unchanged
and if you've been invited to business
negotiations you can take an entire
video with you fantastic a user-friendly
interface and the ability to work with
popular programs led to the emergence of
entire business quarters
large companies are much more likely to
gather employees together in virtual
offices than in real ones nowadays and
this way they can save money on renting
expensive real estate and they can
protect colleagues from the covid
pandemic that is yet to be stopped by
the way way back in 2021 microsoft
specialists found out that 66 of the
company's employees were suffering from
a lack of human contact and 46 couldn't
even communicate with their colleagues
through conventional video conferencing
systems like zoom or skype virtual
offices with good natured avatars have
become an excellent solution to this
problem all programs and applications by
the way are executed directly on meta
servers and we've ultimately forgotten
how to install programs on our computers
your device really only serves as well a
means of displaying the result like a
monitor
now even a high poly 3d model is easy to
correct using a smartphone now the
ability to work with meta through
accessible devices has become an
invaluable factor in the success of the
platform in third world countries people
who previously couldn't afford these
expensive computers or smartphones have
now become a part of this new digital
world each user of the platform can
speak their own language as an automatic
translator much like a babble fish
translates the words into the language
of the interlocutor so meta gradually
erased these digital boundaries that
existed between electronic services
programs and even countries
[Music]
zuckerberg is going even further he's
going to combine three realities the
ordinary the virtual and the augmented
and for this beta engineers are
developing entirely new devices
i never asked for this
look at this vintage smartphone i've got
in my hand now it occupies a very small
part of what my eyes see for me to get
more useful information i need to either
increase the size of my screen or move
it closer to my eyes
now mata actually has a division that
develops unusual electronics i'm talking
virtual and augmented reality helmets
tactile suits and gloves and even
holographic projectors now augmented
reality glasses like these ones are
becoming the simplest and most popular
form of communicating in messer the
first serial samples appeared back in
2012 but manufacturers really only
worked out the kinks in the late 20s the
problems were really to do with the lack
of computing power of the processor and
also the complexity of combining the
beams of laser projectors now such
glasses according to their principal
operation most resemble wireless
headphones of the early 2020s the entire
video stream is formed on a main device
for instance a smartphone or a computer
and the processor and the glasses well
that only decodes the signal as a result
i have a lightweight and comfortable
monitor that's always with me
look let me show you something
just with one command a virtual cabinet
appears before your eyes a projection
with a resolution of 8k is enough for
working with documents and communicating
online more than enough actually the
lenses of these glasses are made with
photochromic glass so at any time they
can be made opaque and fenced off from
the outside world now this is an ideal
tool for work and communication but for
games more serious artillery is needed
ar glasses cannot cope with the standard
240 frames per second for gaming so from
my experience i'd recommend vr helmets
of course initial prototypes failed to
inspire optimism their helmets were too
heavy and cumbersome right hardly anyone
would enjoy wearing something weighing a
couple of kilograms on their head
moreover if you would turn your head
very quickly the processor didn't have
the time to rotate the image correctly
and a delay of a few frames consistently
caused bouts of well sea sickness now
the weight problem was actually solved
by replacing the classical optical
system of several lenses with just one
variable lens this technology has been
known in theory since the end of the
20th century but it was perfected only
in the mid-20s now the virtual reality
helmet weighs less than a kilo it's
quite good comparable to motorcycle
helmets now we've got arrays of powerful
orientation sensors and mobile risk
processes and these have really helped
with picture lag no one gets seasick
anymore with modern helmets but still
helmets remain entertainment for
enclosed spaces only i mean you don't
see people walking down the street in
them nevertheless complete with tactile
suits and gloves they can make games
incredibly realistic from my personal
experience i played black ops 7 the
other week in mine and it was terrific
you just need to remember to air them
out occasionally i mean otherwise the
smell of sweat will probably putrefy
your experience and to disappoint matrix
fans newer interfaces will have to go
through a long and tedious process of
approval with medical organizations
therefore alas i do not think they will
appear on the market before the middle
of the 21st century
[Music]
well since meta has been designed to
break boundaries it'd be strange to use
some standard form of payment right
in order to remain separate from the
banking system and not to
be afraid of interference from financial
authorities metazone cryptocurrency was
created officially it's the only means
of payment with meta it serves for the
purchase of virtual assets nfts
subscriptions to streaming services and
also the rental of electric cars
moreover it's accepted as a payment
method on all marketplaces bureaucrats
from the european union initially tried
to ban this currency but the business
quickly found a way out now we're making
orders not directly but rather through
intermediaries registered in states free
from unnecessary and restricting laws
order new users didn't even notice this
end-to-end authorization and mandatory
tracking of digital fingerprints of all
devices on the network are laid down at
the level of meta's core protocols a
couple of years ago meta returned to
experimenting with unconditional income
which is quite interesting now each user
of the metaverse is entitled to a fixed
monthly premium it's quite enough for a
basic set of products and basic
necessities this measure has become a
real salvation for millions of people
around the world who have lost their
jobs we're talking truckers shipping
crews and couriers i mean they've all
been replaced by autonomous delivery
vehicles from tiny quadrocopters to
large multi-axle road trains what large
states have not dared to do the largest
private company is actively implementing
it's hardly surprising that zuckerberg
connectedverse is now more than two
billion regular users
[Music]
well
let's get back to the present for a
minute would you like to live in such a
world i mean i admit i'm a bit alarmed
by meta's ambitions mark zuckerberg
missed the chance to participate in the
mobile revolution when the smartphone
market was forming facebook was still
pretty weak player perhaps that's why
mark didn't want to postpone the master
any longer
now i support the decision to start with
hardware and protocols but i'm afraid of
the company's desire to explore and
control the social graph i've already
told you more than once about the amount
of information collected by t giant you
know facebook apple and google so i'm
not going to repeat myself there on the
other hand without the support of other
market players zuckerberg's new universe
would just turn into another second life
just with blockchain and augmented
reality the most recent breakthrough has
been mobile internet with this advent we
got used to the internet literally being
always at hand
but whether we'll ever get used to
living inside the information we're now
having to search for i think we'll find
out in a dozen years or so that is how
much time zuckerberg thinks it will take
to create his metaverse
well my name is bradley and i hope we'll
meet plenty of times before that
universe ever materializes and i'd like
to thank you for joining another
scintillating space age saddleback sneak
between the shaggy and spry succulents
of the online jungle i will see you in
the next video thanks for joining us
[Music]
welcome to the brand new metadata